he was thinking more about y'all or then
I said look we're not gonna get anywhere
I'm staying here we're just gonna stay
in the same hole the only reason I sold
the house
it was dead I'm broke we was doing quite
a bit I mean it was a couple ounces a
day our habit was $2,500 a day if not
more that's 25 grand to Eddie I mean you
take two we're done it wasn't something
that just started and I my god I started
using drugs you found out that I got
busted it wasn't I got high because I
wanted to it's not the first time I've
ever done drugs and you know that
nobody's been the first time since like
we've been older that you ever been
strung out the thing is like you can't
get clean and then gee no not get clean
you have to understand to like I can't
have Ella and along I around a half and
I promise you for the last couple months
we have been I would say 90% good if
this was four or five months ago I would
have been high school when I came up in
here I'm glad that you weren't look I'm
at the point now like I'm kind of done
with um like because I don't like the
way that he is treated to you where you
gonna run [ __ ] are you stupid
I don't even understand quite honestly
why you are still with him he has done
you dirty like he moved into the house
and then it was like he was pushing me
out yeah he's done some good and yeah
I've stood beside him but why cuz you
would have never took him out from sugar
bear ever after all the you tell us not
to like why can't you take that advice
for yourself do you feel that love about
yourself that you just think you deserve
to be treated like that or I don't
[Music]